on va retenir son nom sur ses lignes
dures parce que ces unions valent à la
question vous est posée c'est devient
telle paranoïa qui paraît qu
effectivement un il paraît pour le
moment vous avez dans le reportage dans
qu'elle a dû annuler un jésus ni
l'europe n'est pas annulé mais
normalement elle n'annule pas ldk lala
vraiment annuler l dickens maladies auto
immunes et paraît qu'en ce moment elle
allongée toute la journée ce sont des
amis québécoises qui ont dit ça allait
allonger chez être la journée qu'elle
entendait voir notamment et pardon c'est
pas drôle même si j'ai envie de rire
elle entend rené voilà qui veut parler
de ça annonce je crois je ne crois pas
il ya des j'y crois j'y crois pas alors
pourquoi tu crois pas guillaume ce qu'on
connaît bien c'est une dure pas on a
fait beaucoup de documentaires avec avec
sur elle et dernièrement on était avec
michel drucker en fait c'est quelqu'un
qui juste en ce moment est malade
qui est une maladie et qui a dit
j'annule mais céline dion c'est pas
quelqu'un qui est comme nous peut-être
que depuis quatre qu'elle a 14 ans on
lui dit fais un peu comme britney fait
ça a fait ça mais sauf que ces lignes à
rené d'airial est ce que nous vu ce que
nous racontent les gens qui sont dans
son entourage
c'est que là notamment pendant le coït
ça a été formidable pour elle parce que
pour la première fois de sa vie elle a
pu vivre normalement comme une maman
c'est à dire que je dors que la vie de
céline dion elle elle finissait concert
tard donc tout est décalé et toute la
famille dès qu'elle est les enfants vont
pas à l'école quand elles rendent le
spectacle par exemple c'est là où le
dîner commence donc il est tard elle a
des petits enfants donc en fait pendant
le coc vide et grâce aux qu'ovide elle a
pu enfin apprendre ce que c'était qu'un
petit déjeuner elle a pu enfin vivre
normalement qu'à la patte de crédit à
l'epad carte de michel drucker nous dit
on fait vraiment aidé dans un avion être
comme elle travaille tout le temps tout
le temps il ya même quelqu'un avec une
assiette kader est qu dit il faut que tu
manges il faut que tu manges il faut que
tu manges c'est une fille qui a une vie
d'athlète oui par exemple la scène à las
vegas personne ne sait elle est penché
comme ça et ce qui fait que l es deux
bouts ouais et ella ella un mal de chien
au talon donc ça lui nécessite en
sortant deux concerts à peu près une
heure de massage pour faire que ces
mules ses muscles se serait star
américaine quoi c'est ce à quoi je crois
donc mais moi j'y crois malheureusement
et ça me chagrine d'y croire mais quand
on la voit évidemment elle est fatiguée
évidemment c'est plus la céline ni
84 ans elle a mon âge ma fille tu es
gentil non mais t'as pas eu savez mon
bébé calme-toi quand même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
guillaume a eu raison de les souligner
bien sûr qu'elle a une vie hors norme et
qu'elle a tout vécu de façon hors norme
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui elle est
crevé céline dion c'est clair pas de pas
de coloration dans les cheveux pas de
make-up elle entend des voix et moi j'y
crois le problème c'est ça c'est que je
crois qu'elle commence à entendre
regarder même ouais je crois qu'elle les
photos des paparazzi c'est la première
fois qu'on la voit comme ça c'est ce qui
met fin à l'avancée de ses deux jumeaux
chef d'antenne journée où l'on sent que
voilà c'est une femme et ses enfants
c'est parce que pour la première fois
vous voyez madame tout le monde et des
stars on attend qu'ils ne soient pas
belle n'a jamais dit guillaume la vérité
s'est classé moi je suis un peu d'accord
final à 54 ans il faudrait qu'elle se
repose paraît-il deux ans en devenir
elle aura 56 ans petite info aussi elle
chante déjà un octave de moi parce
qu'elle va les avocats c'est anormal en
face à un dilemme il oppose l'aï pas
comment la mecque pardon c'est horrible
de dire ça mais les séparer mais ça se
fera par les nombreuses et oui pardon tu
essaies de 50 ans tu as eu aussi des
problèmes de bouffées de chaleur de
machin de fatigue de tom et annule
parata nullement une tournée m'attendais
go go go go sa soeur a pris la parole
est dit exactement ce qu'a dit laurent
elle a dit alors préménopause en plus en
plus face à qui justifient d'un public
d'honneur pré ménopause
mais il parle du syndrome de guillain
barré je sais pas si vous connaissez
cette maladie qu'est auto immunes moi
j'ai été confronté à sa très récemment
que jamais proche qui vient de s'en
sortir de cette maladie mais vraiment
c'est taiwo c'est quoi c'est une maladie
qu'on déclare du jour au lendemain on ne
peut plus marcher on est allongé dans un
lit pendant 6 mois à l'hôpital on ne
peut rien serré avec ses mains on n'a
plus de force et pour s'en sortir c'est
de la rééducation très très compliqué là
si elle marche ça veut dire qu'elle est
en train de s'en sortir mais c'est une
maladie très grave vraiment pas ça sénat
pour monsieur je sais pas ce que c'était
bien comme conséquence d'accord il faut
oui oui je me demandais s'il était parmi
croit la maladie c'est très triste
évidemment merval est ce qu'elle est
parano appartement elle entend toujours
honneur ce problème quelque part quand
même
il est battu sur la moitié des idées
qu'on dit qu'on aimait la depuis tout à
l'heure sont absolument pas contrôler ça
j'avais dit non mais rogers on dirait
que
on attend tous les gens qui disent taxes
et sa famille et vous savez que mon fils
à la ménopause des pirates avaient bon
c'est quand même et qui le dit sa peur
non et ipam qu'elle entend durant un
délai d' ivoire une caméra est ou non un
nom dans les magazines elle a dit
qu'elle était fatiguée elle était
monopole qu'elle avait la ménopause elle
n'a pas dit jean l'année doit de la
tournée est annulée
parallèle à faire entre rené et céline
et laeticia et johnny c'est à dire
qu'elle a toujours dit qu'elle parlait à
rené même les années qui ont suivi la
mort de renée elle avait un espèce de
moulage de ces jeunes qu'elle allait
serrer avant de rentrer sur scène donc à
la fourrure est à regarder dans les
neiges vont
plaire aujourd'hui tu attends pas tant
qu'une rue lâche de sa main qu'il aucune
blague jean michel reconnaît pour les
dépenses et voilà moulage de la [ __ ]
mais
[Applaudissements]
non sexe mais elle allait pas brûlé les
ailes et a mené 2 sets 0 nice est mort à
là parce que du moule pas
n'aurait pas coûté cher aux bleus encore
pardon oui non voilà je pense qu'elle a
cette
conjugaison amoureuse qu'elle avait avec
renée elle aura jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
est ce que leur a d'ailleurs quelqu'un
d'autre à mon avis non je pense qu'elle
n'a pas envie de refaire sa vie parce
que le grenelle a toujours à ses côtés
non non elle n'est pas sortie serait
passé il ya eu il ya eu son styliste
avec qui on a dit bon quelque chose et c
est ce qu on peut dire aussi qu'on peut
dire quelque chose mais depuis qu rené
mort ait eu un succès qui a été écrit
par jane goldman met à poil à et après
pardon plus rien à la demande à son fils
est manager mais son fils il a 21 ans et
il fait du rap il en a rien à [ __ ] de
la soul de sa mère
je l'adoré
c'est une amie mais on dit la vérité
depuis la mort de rené rené c'était
comment ça va bien la chanteuse qui
chante e bay s'est mis en colère comment
s'appelle déjà yann mathieu merci
mathieu elle avait à laver stark à côte
et où séjourna 14 ont perdu leurs
mondiaux renier ça s'est arrêté il ya
cinq ans elle a sorti un album 4 canepa
par génieau langue et non mais off bah
oui c'est parce qu'il adore mais non
c'est que je suis pragmatique enfin ça
ça n'existe pas une star qui toute sa
vie
tous les albums sont des cartons de
celui là très bien marché pas
incroyablement bien marché mais elle en
a sorti un ou deux livres j'ai dire
quelque chose titanic elle voulait pas
le faire rené la force et ses traits
plus grands tubes ex des glaces elle
voulait pas y aller fait tout au plus
grand carton également ne voulait pas de
rencontre était disons plus grands cuir
phares dont toutes les décisions qu à la
pompe c'était une connerie elle a dit
que le sud sa boussole alors pardon de
te le dire ça oui à un moment telle
décision c'était rené pourquoi
pas
agacé vous faites est né alors que
j'adore c'est une amie
[Rires]
possible ça alors ça m'a
servier à l'entreprise existe aussi
l'andropause existe six
tient laurent alors on sait que ça peut
arriver aussi c'est pas parce que tarzan
n'est pas touché par ça
ça tu arriveras à mon grand
ça tu arriveras ça tu arriveras